- Oh, my goodness.
- Hello.
- What a beautiful studio.
- I know. We're excited, thank you.
- They told me they didn't
have money for nice studios.
- I love being in this building with you.
- It's a great building.
- I have to say this, you
are the very first person,
when we announced that we
were coming to New York,
he sent me a handwritten card.
Saying, "Welcome to 30 Rock.
I'll show you around the commissary."
Which by the way, has really good food.
- It's an excellent commissary.
That was the first thing
I was gonna tell you.
- When you said it in the card,
and you brought up food,
I was like, I don't know.
Because a cafeteria, it can be suspect
- I started here in 2001,
and the cafeteria in 2001 was a dump.
- Okay, okay. I came at the right time.
- They rebuilt the commissary
and I take it to the streets.
I brag about it everywhere I go.
- It's so good.
- Yeah, it's really great.
You do have to pay for the food.
I've heard about you at previous places.
There's an assumption because
you're Kelly Clarkson,
you can just take the
food and walk right out.
But I do need you to stop.
- Well, I'm here now 30 Rock.
I want free food. (laughs)
No, I love the building.
But I know that you have a
crazy story with your doorman.
- Yeah, first of all,
it's so exciting to be
in a room with all these
New York City doorman.
- I know.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Because you see them every day.
- But I'll say, because you're all here,
I walked to the building,
there are so many unsigned
for packages outside.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Buildings right now.
- It's ridiculous.
- Just littering the streets.
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah, I think I have
the best doorman story.
- You do.
- In New York City.
Which is my wife, we were
on our way to deliver...
She was gonna deliver, we decided.
She was pregnant with our second.
Her water broke and we
went out to the Uber.
And we walked right back inside
because she said, "It's
happening right now."
And so she gave birth in our very...
We have a very small lobby.
When I say lobby, I think people
picture something a lot bigger.
It is not grand.
And my wife fully gave birth in our lobby
and we had two doormen on that day.
And I would say one of
them rose to the occasion
and the other one sort
of sunk to the floor.
- The other one's like
the Homer Simpson gif.
You know, like backing into the bush.
- He did very quietly sort of
became part of the wallpaper.
But it's great.
He's now sort of just...
Our our middle son Axle, he's
just part of the building now.
Everybody loves lobby baby.
- I think that's what you don't...
Lobby baby, I love that it's lobby baby.
- [Seth] We call him lobby baby.
- Do your kids know this
now that they're older?
- Do they know?
- Yes.
So we got three.
(audience applauds)
By the way-
- Oh my god, so cute.
- In case you're
wondering, which is the kid
that was born in the lobby,
it's the one with a box on his head.
So it it is having long lasting effects.
Yeah, they know he's
lobby and it's really...
I feel for my seven-year-old,
because they'll go out
and I'll be in the park
and people will come up
and they'll say, "Which
one is lobby baby?"
And the older one says, "He's lobby baby.
I'm hospital baby."
(audience laughs)
- Oh.
- And I don't have the heart
to tell him nobody cares.
Hospital baby is the most
common of all the babies.
- Oh my god, don't tell that.
- But then we have our
third one, a bathtub baby.
Did you know that?
- No.
- Yeah, not by accident.
It wasn't like my wife was in a bathroom
and was like, "Oh, boy."
- You are just trying
to make all your kids feel special.
- Yes.
Yeah, we had a home birth.
We had a planned home birth.
- Oh, you planned it?
- Well, the doormen planned it.
They said, we don't...
(audience laughs)
They said, "We have come
up with a plan for you.
When you have the baby,
Don't come down here again"
- Oh, my god.
Your wife is like a Viking,
having babies everywhere.
I'm like, "What?"
- Yeah, she's basically
going through the city.
She wants to do Staten Island Ferry next.
We're really excited.
- Okay. Okay.
A lot of kids in that house.
- We're gonna have a lot of kids, yeah.
- No, you-time anymore.
I'm excited to experience Halloween here
'cause I have kids as well.
So what is trick-or-treating like?
Do your kids have costumes already?
- Yeah, so the five-year-old
always picks right away.
He usually picks like November
3rd of the previous year.
And he's gonna be a gecko from this-
- Oh, "PJ Masks."
- "PJ Masks."
So he's a gecko.
The older one, he can't make a decision.
He's currently a wasp, but it's too early.
That'll change.
- Like, "The Wasp," the superhero
or just the wasp?
- Just like a wasp.
- A wasp, got it.
- He's like, "I just
wanna be a mediocre wasp.
- Just an average wasp.
- And then, the baby,
we're gonna put the baby
in the same lamb costume
that the kids have worn.
- Oh, you have one that's passed down?
- We just have... Yeah.
There you go. Those are the lambs.
Those are when the boys were younger.
- That's cute.
- Yeah.
- When it was sweet.
You were like, "When they were younger."
- I was, I'm like, "Oh, I miss those two."
- [Kelly] Remember when they liked me?
- Now they're walking around
me like, "I wanna be a wasp!"
- So wait, this is your 10th anniversary?
- We had our 10th
anniversary on September 1st.
Yeah.
- Wow.
- Pretty exciting.
(audience applauds)
- Statistics are against, just saying.
- Statistics are against you.
They say for families who
have a child in the lobby,
they almost never make it.
(Kelly laughs)
- Or maybe that's the key.
You could do anything together, anywhere.
- Have a baby in a lobby,
if you can do that-
you can save-
- I love that.
- Do you have a secret?
- We do not have a secret.
- You're just a good listener?
- No, I think we just,
we fit well together.
We have a very complimentary skills.
- That must have been my problem. Okay.
Your podcast, you have it
with your brother, right?
- Yeah, we have a podcast called
"Family Trips with the Myers Brothers."
And it's me and my brother.
We talk to it's celebrities
and interesting people
about the trips they took
as kids and almost no...
There we are as kids, look at us.
- [Kelly] Like when we
never wore seat belts?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Nobody.
- Nope.
- It's amazing how many of
us lived to tell the tale.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I mean, in the 70s it
was just so many kids
just sliding around in the
back of station wagons.
- Or they'd put one of the kids up
in the window shield part in the back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was a lot of, you talk to people
and they're like, "Yeah,
our parents would put
a card table in the back
of the station wagon.
We'd play poker for eight hours."
You can't believe how little...
- I rode in the back of the
truck, the pickup truck.
Now it's illegal, but I was like,
"This is the greatest thing ever."
- Very happy to say, everybody survived
and they have good
stories about being kids.
- I love the podcast with
your brother, though.
That's so cool.
I love my sister so much.
That would be so much fun to do with her.
- It's nice. You need a reason
to talk to your siblings one hour a week.
And that's what we found.
- Well, my sister and I
talk to each other a lot.
(Seth laughs)
But any memorable trips with your kids?
- The most memorable for me-
- Do they wear seat belts now?
- They do, double seat belts.
We took our kids to Uruguay.
My wife has very grand ideas of what
we can accomplish with young kids.
And Uruguay, one of the most
beautiful place I've ever been.
But our flight got delayed
and so it was supposed to
be 12 hours, it was 24.
And I was the most tired I've ever been.
And at one point, Axel was two,
and I had his stroller
and I looked down and he wasn't there.
And I said to Alexi, "I
don't know where Axel is."
And she said, "You're
holding him in your arms."
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And I was so tired that I looked down,
I was like, "Well, he's gone forever."
(audience laughs)
- You know what, people don't get that.
You get a certain level of
tired that you literally...
I guess normal people without kids,
it's when your sunglasses
are on your head.
But it's more important
'cause it's a human.
But yeah...
- Alexi said the most
damning thing wasn't that
I didn't know he was
there, but when she said,
"Oh, he's not lost forever,
you're holding him,"
my reaction was like, "Okay."
(Kelly laughs)
I wasn't even like, "Oh, thank goodness!"
- He's fine.
- I kind of liked the idea
that he was just lost.
- Oh, my god.
Seth did another podcast over the strike
with other late night hosts,
which I thought was brilliant.
- Yeah, it was 12 episodes.
We had a lot of free time on our hands.
"Strike Force Five.
- But I thought it was really cool too
because a lot of people in this industry,
pits us against each other.
And I thought it was really cool too
that everybody was
together doing something.
- It was super nice.
There've been different era of late night
where the hosts didn't get
along as well as we do now.
It was just for a good cause.
We were raising money
to help out our staffs
during the writer's strike.
Obviously, we have a lot of similarities
but the longer we did the podcast,
I think we found our different lanes.
And it was a dream.
It was really nice.
- I thought it was a
really cool idea as well.
- Yeah, credit to Jimmy Kimmel
who had the idea for the podcast.
- Yeah, I love him, yeah.
Let's do another break.
"Late Night with Seth
Myers" airs weeknights
at 12:35 AM on NBC and
streams on Peacock, everybody.
And don't miss Seth's podcast.
It's called "Family Trips
with the Myers Brothers."
It's available wherever
you get your podcasts.
We will be right back.